>> Sean: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT SOMEBODY ELSE,
TUCKER.
THANK YOU FOR THAT WARM
INTRODUCTION.
GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
A LOT OF GROUND TO COVER.
MORE LAWLESSNESS SHOCKINGLY IN
SEATTLE BUT WE DO A VIDEO THAT
WILL SHOCK YOU FROM A GRUESOME
ASSAULT IN NEW YORK CITY AND
MUCH MORE TONIGHT.
WE BEGIN WITH SOME GOOD NEWS, MY
HEART NOT AS TROUBLED.
HOW DO YOU LIKE THAT?
GOOD NEWS, WE NEED GOOD NEWS.
IT LOOKS LIKE TONIGHT WE CAN SAY
THAT A ROBUST, V-SHAPED ECONOMIC
RECOVERY MIGHT COME OUT LOOKING
GOOD, BE UNDERWAY.
BRAND-NEW NUMBERS, LOOK AT THIS,
RETAIL SALES IN THE MONTH OF MAY
BROKE ALL EXPECTATIONS RISING BY
NEARLY 18% AND THAT’S DOUBLE THE
MOST RECENT FORECAST AND IT IS
THE HIGHEST MONTHLY GAIN IN THE
HISTORY OF THE U.S.
LET ME REPEAT THAT, THAT IS THE
HIGHEST MONTHLY GAIN IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
NOW IT’S VERY CLEAR AS MORE THAN
EVER THAT IN 140 DAYS, YOU, WE
THE PEOPLE FACE A PIVOTAL MOMENT
MOMENT, THIS IS A CROSSROADS
ELECTION.
CAPITALISM, SOCIALISM, PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH, APPEASEMENT,
OPEN BORDERS, SANCTUARY CITIES,
SANCTUARY STATES, SECURE BORDERS
BORDERS, GOVERNMENT TAKEOVER OF
INDUSTRY AND CONFISCATING, FREE
MARKET ENERGY INDEPENDENCE AND
CONSTITUTIONALISTS ON THE BENCH,
A LOT AT STAKE IN 140 DAYS.
WE’RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO ALSO
MAKE ECONOMIC PROGRESS WITH THE
PRESIDENT’S PRO-GROWTH AGENDA
AND DESCEND INTO THE ALWAYS
PREDICTABLE, ALWAYS, ALWAYS,
ALWAYS, MY NEW BOOK "LIVE FREE
OR DIE," THE FAILURES OF
SOCIALISM.
THEY WANT TO REPEAT WHAT WE KNOW
WILL FAIL AND DO SIMPLE ABACUS
OR CALCULATOR WOULD SHOW THEM
THAT BUT THEY DON’T CARE.
HOW DID OBAMACARE WORK OUT FOR
YOU?
AS WE COUNT DOWN TO ELECTION
DAY, ASK YOURSELF THIS QUESTION.
IN BIDEN’S FOUR PLUS DECADES AS
A SENATOR, EIGHT YEARS AS
VICE PRESIDENT, WHAT DID HE EVER
DO TO HELP IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
YOU, WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, ALL
AMERICANS?
WHAT DID THEY DO TO IMPROVE
POLICE, COMMUNITY RELATIONS WHEN
THEY HELD THE HIGHEST OFFICES IN
THE LAND FOR EIGHT YEARS?
DID THEY IMPROVE RELATIONS AFTER
THE RIOTS IN FERGUSON, MISSOURI?
ASK YOURSELF, DID THEY IMPROVE
THEM AFTER THE RIOTS IN
BALTIMORE, MARYLAND, FREDDIE
GRAY, DID THEY IMPROVE THEM BY
INFLAMING TENSIONS, CAMBRIDGE
POLICE AND MANY OTHER INCIDENTS?
NO, OF COURSE NOT, THEY FANNED
THE FLAMES, RUSH TO JUDGMENT,
VILIFIED POLICE OFFICER STANDING
CASE AFTER CASE AFTER CASE THERE
RUSH TO JUDGMENT WAS WRONG.
AND AS FOR SOLUTIONS, WHAT ARE
THEY DO?
NOTHING.
AND BY THE WAY, YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS, THEY DO ANYTHING TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
AMERICANS ESPECIALLY MINORITY
AMERICANS WHO LIVE IN SOME OF
AMERICA’S BIGGEST CITIES RUN BY
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS AND MAYORS
FOR DECADES AND DECADES?
DID THEY IMPROVE THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM?
AT THE END OF THE OBAMA-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
GUESS WHAT, THIRD HIGHEST PER
CAPITA SPENDING CITY IN AMERICA.
BALTIMORE.
IN BALTIMORE THEY HAD 13 PUBLIC
HIGH SCHOOLS THAT HAD ZERO
STUDENTS PROFICIENT IN MATH.
ZERO.
MEANWHILE, IN OBAMA’S HOMETOWN,
WE WATCHED THE VIOLENCE ALL
THROUGHOUT THE EIGHT YEARS HE
WAS PRESIDENT, VIOLENT CRIME
EXPLODED AND HE BARELY MENTIONED
IT, A FEW TIMES, THAT’S IT.
DID HE DO ANYTHING?
KNOW.
INTO AS A 9-2016, 4,000
AMERICANS WERE MURDERED IN HIS
HOMETOWN CITY, THE WINDY CITY.
SO MANY THOUSANDS OF OTHERS
INJURED.
AND VIRTUALLY EVERY MAJOR
LIBERAL CITY IN THE COUNTRY WE
SEE A SIMILAR TREND.
NOT HARD TO FIGURE OUT, VIOLENT
CRIME WAY UP IN LOS ANGELES.
NEW YORK, WAY UP.
MINNEAPOLIS, WAY UP.
CRIME SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL
IN ALMOST EVERY MAJOR
DEMOCRATIC-RUN CITY AND STATE
BUT FINALLY WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
THAT IS WILLING TO TAKE ACTION.
WE’RE GOING TO COMPARE AND
CONTRAST THE PRESIDENT’S FULL
RECORD OF COMPLIMENT COMING UP
TONIGHT.
WE START WITH THE PRESIDENT’S
BRAND-NEW ORDER ON POLICING.
BY THE WAY, THINGS THAT JOE AND
BARACK NEVER DID.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AMERICANS BELIEVE WE MUST
SUPPORT THE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN
IN BLUE WHO BELIEVES OUR STREETS
AND KEEP US SAFE.
INVEST MORE RESOURCES IN POLICE
TRAINING, RECRUITING, AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
TODAY I’M SIGNING AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER ENCOURAGING POLICE
DEPARTMENTS NATIONWIDE TO ADOPT
THE HIGHEST PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THEY ARE GREAT MEN AND WOMEN.
WHEN OTHERS RUN AWAY FROM
DANGER, POLICE RUN STRAIGHT INTO
HARM’S WAY, OFTEN PUTTING THEIR
LIVES AT STAKE TO PROTECT
SOMEONE WHO THEY DON’T KNOW OR
NEVER EVEN MET.
>> Sean: WITH HIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
INCREASING POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH A NATIONWIDE DATABASE THAT
DOCUMENTS EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE
CLAIMS, IMPACTFUL IN BOTH THE
FLOYD SITUATION AND WHAT
HAPPENED IN ATLANTA.
BOTH TIMES, THE ORDER ALSO SET
GUIDELINES FOR POLICE
TRANSPARENCY, BANS THE USE OF
CHOKE HOLDS UNLESS AN OFFICER’S
LIFE IS AT RISK AND YOU KNOW,
GUESS WHAT?
ALL HOLDS BARRED TO SAVE YOUR
LIFE.
DURING THE EIGHT YEARS IN
OFFICE, BARACK, JOE, THEY DIDN’T
DO ONE OF THESE THINGS, NOT A
SINGLE ONE.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ACTUALLY,
HE’S TALKING TO EVERYONE,
INCORPORATING ALL SIDES INTO HIS
POLICY DECISIONS AND EARLIER
TODAY EVEN ONE FORMER OBAMA
OFFICIAL ACTUALLY HAD,
SHOCKINGLY, SURPRISINGLY IT
RIGHTFULLY PRAYS FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
FAMILIES THERE WHO SPOKE
DIRECTLY WITH THE PRESIDENT,
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR AND ALSO
WITH TIM SCOTT AND ALL THOSE
LAW-ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE WERE
LISTENING AND THEY BASICALLY
JUST TOLD THEIR STORY WHICH
APPARENTLY ACCORDING TO PEOPLE I
TALKED TO, THERE WERE TEARS AND
THE PRESIDENT WAS KIND AND
GRACIOUS TO THEM.
THAT DID NOT TURN INTO A BIG
PHOTO OP OR A BIG MEDIA MOMENT.
THAT WAS MORE OF A PROCESS OF
TRYING TO MOVE THIS WHITE HOUSE
FORWARD AND I THINK THOSE
FAMILIES FEEL GOOD ABOUT HAVING
A CHANCE TO TELL THOSE STORIES
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
I AGREE WITH THE LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATION, THE PIECES THAT ARE
BEING PUT IN PLACE NOW ARE NOT
ADEQUATE BUT THEY ARE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
>> Sean: ALSO MORE THAN BARACK
AND JOE DID.
NOT EVERYONE WAS HAPPY WITH THE
PRESIDENT’S EXECUTIVE ORDER,
DEMOCRATS ACCUSED HIM OF NOT
GOING FAR ENOUGH.
WHY DIDN’T YOU SAY THAT A
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA AND
VICE PRESIDENT FORGETFUL
JOE BIDEN?
THE MEDIA MOB WERE UPSET THAT
RACE DID NOT PLAY A MORE
PROMINENT ROLE IN THE ORDER.
MOMENTS AGO, LET’S TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT HE HE SAID.
>> YOU CAN’T REALLY FIX THE
HEART OF PEOPLE BUT YOU CAN FIX
INDIVIDUAL PIECES THAT DEAL WITH
THE REAL PROBLEMS WHICH IS
ACCESS, OPPORTUNITY, IF YOU TALK
ABOUT THE POLICE FORCE, IT’S
ABOUT HAVING POLICE FORCE THAT
REPRESENTS THE COMMUNITY, ACCESS
TO EDUCATION, ACCESS TO CAPITAL,
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE ARE
REALLY DEALING WITH.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, AS THE
PRESIDENT SAYS AT THE END OF HIS
RALLY, WE HAVE ONE GLORIOUS
NATION UNDER GOD, WE ARE ONE
AMERICAN FAMILY, ALL OF OUR
CITIZENS, ALL OF YOU, WE ARE ONE
FAMILY, WE ARE ALL IMPORTANT.
THAT’S WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP,
THAT’S WHY HE PASSED PRISON
REFORM.
THAT WASN’T BARACK AND THAT
WASN’T JOE, IT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO GOT
NONVIOLENT FIRST OFFENDERS OUT
OF JAIL.
AGAIN, NOT OBAMA, NOT BIDEN, IT
WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO OFFERED
A CLEMENCY.
THAT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
PARDONED ANGELA STANTON KING.
NOT BARACK OBAMA, JOE BIDEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MASSIVELY
INCREASED FUNDING TO
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
AGAIN, THEY HAD EIGHT YEARS.
OBAMA, BIDEN DID NOTHING.
IT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
DEVELOPED A SPECIAL TAX-FREE
OPPORTUNITY ZONE TO LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AGAIN, JOE AND BARACK, THEY DID
NOTHING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP OVERSAW WHAT WAS
THE GREATEST ECONOMIC SURGE FOR
EVERY AMERICAN DEMOGRAPHIC.
ALL AMERICANS, THAT DID NOT
HAPPEN, JUST THE OPPOSITE
HAPPENED UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND THE FORGETFUL VP JOE BIDEN.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT,
AFRICAN-AMERICAN YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT, RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT AFTER RECORD LOW
AFTER RECORD LOW.
NOW, LOOK AT THE EARLY NUMBERS,
THINGS ARE BOUNCING BACK QUICKER
THAN I THOUGHT THEY EVER WOULD.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GETTING
BACK ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL TO
CONNECT WITH VOTERS IN PERSON AT
RALLIES.
NOT BIDEN, I’M FINE WITH HIM, HE
ONLY SEES TWO PEOPLE A DAY, STAY
IN THE BASEMENT.
HE’S TERRIFIED, APPARENTLY, TO
LIVE IN HIS HOUSE.
SOME IN THE MOB AND THE MEDIA
AND OTHERS DON’T WANT THE
PRESIDENT TO HAVE RALLY, THEY’RE
GOING TO GO WITH A LAWSUIT.
THEY CLAIM THAT THE PRESIDENT’S
UPCOMING RALLIES ARE PUTTING
LIVES AT RISK BUT THEY HAVE ZERO
PROBLEM WITH THE MASS PROTESTS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY THE PAST
TWO WEEKS, MANY DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS EVEN THE EVER, CLOSE
DOWN EVERYTHING GOVERNOR OF
MICHIGAN, MAYBE THAT PRESIDENT
JUST CALLED THE VALLEY OF
PROTEST AND EVERYTHING’S FINE,
THE MEDIA WON’T CRITICIZE YOU.
CALL IT A PROTEST AGAINST
SOCIALISM OR A PROTEST AGAINST
FORGETFUL JOE.
AS ELECTION NEARS, IT’S
IMPORTANT TO ASK WHO YOU TRUST
TO GET THE ECONOMY BACK ON
TRACK.
THEY FAILED FOR EIGHT YEARS.
LET’S SEE, 13 MORE MILLION
AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS.
LOWEST HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE IN 50
YEARS, WORST RECOVERY SINCE THE
’40s AND ACCUMULATED MORE DEBT
THAN EVERY PRESIDENT BEFORE THEM
COMBINED AND DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED, YEAH, MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
WHO WILL YOU TRUST TO FIX
AMERICA’S CITIES, WHO DO YOU
TRUST TO IMPROVE POLICING AND
END OF THE UNREST AND DO YOU
TRUST TO THE EVER JOE BIDEN WHO
HAS BEEN IN THE WASHINGTON
SWAMP?
WHAT HAS HE DONE IN 40 YEARS?
HE HAS LITTLE TO SHOW FOR IT.
DO YOU TRUST PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
MOVED AT LIGHTNING SPEED TO MAKE
THE COUNTRY A BETTER PLACE AND
KEPT HIS PROMISES, THAT WAS
REFRESHING.
IN 140 DAYS, I’M BEGINNING TO
FEEL THE URGENCY.
I CAN’T DECIDE THIS ELECTION BUT
YOU CAN, YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WILL BE THE ULTIMATE
JURY.
YOUR DECISION WILL IMPACT THIS
COUNTRY FOR DECADES TO COME.
AND I’M SAYING BASED ON WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING AND PROPOSING
THAT WE ALL KNOW HAS FAILED,
THIS COUNTRY WILL BE
UNRECOGNIZABLE, IN MY OPINION,
FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN IF GOD FORBID THEY
WIN.
I WROTE A BOOK, IT’S COMING OUT
AUGUST 4TH, YOU CAN GO TO
Amazon.com, Hannity.com.
THE REASON I WROTE IT IS BECAUSE
THIS IS THE TIPPING POINT, THIS
IS THE MOMENT, EVERYTHING IS AT
STAKE HERE, THIS IS NOT A GAME.
YOU WANT THE COUNTRY, FREEDOM
AND LIBERTY?
THAT’S THE COUNTRY THAT WILL BE